When you wrote your winner and
loser methods,
you may have gotten an error
reading something like this.
No visible interface for 'RPSTurn'
declares the selector 'defeats'.
Selector here refers to the message or
the method being called.
And interface refers to
the public interface for
RPSTurn that's found in its header file.
Defeats is not visible to the winner and
loser methods.
Because, just like we saw with
properties, in order for a method to be
visible outside of its class it must
be included in the header file.
So we'll open up the header file for
RPSturn.
And we'll include
the defeats method here.
Now if we go back to our winner and
loser methods, we can see that
the compiler error has gone away.